皆さんは降らずうっていうものを知っていますでしょうかジョイント式のフラップです
これは普通のフラフープと何が違うかといいますと
とてもねー細いんですよこういう感じでバラバラにあるこういうちょっとまかった方を
高熱投げてできると色によって相性とかあんのかね全然変な奴が生んだけどエベル
うーんこれ女ん大変なのは創刊の後先輩硬いんですけどああいう1ぞって最後県ぜ
動か2つ入っ
うーん以上今日のメインチャンネルでさバイバーイ
じゃあを笑うこれ待って本当にこれ車って
檻さあこれさー
たくさん買ってるんでこれを作業はおまからたくさん止めて言って言葉じゃどんなゾロ
失敗だった日はい感じです
大変なんですけどこいつらフープを作れます僕らじうむなるのだ自信がありますよ
これ吠えてるわけねえっ
終わってるなら造形が飛び出すと r 同部酒のもんだけど全然普通にできます
いやー
それが全部が普通に出来るんですけども今回このフラフープはなるべく中にしてみまし
た
普通はこうつけるんですけど客の pop に回すとこれからこの状況と姉なんか
最後まで行っちゃうとそれのフライトになるんですけどもすこす死ねってやると薄く
閉めた状態だとこのね何とも言えないね8なるんですよそれきれいな円にならない状態
ですきれいな円にならないぞー
左右なるべくの橋のば雪ノ下つなげてつなぎつなげていくトーンとなーんとですね超
巨大なグループができると思いません
プラグっていうの円の中で動くわけなんで演じたい大きくすると1回の改善による
カロリーの孫氏が春だろーってくるとぶっかけたわけです
なので今日はジョイントしながら空港なるべくつなげて巨大なプロフ
を作ってそれで今日ダイエットクリア地がダイエットじゃないよ僕の場合は運動不足
ですから運動音してる体を健康にしたいと思ってるんで巨大グループをつくってみるは
終わっておりますでは行こう
もう入ってるはどんどんつなげていきますよ
me
はい一応完成しましたこんな感じですねちょっと形はいびつなんですけども
あーちょっくらグーッとしての機能は北へになってるね
パネル大部分です裏早速回すいきましょう
ほ
でマーサーかそんな危ないことするわけないですよ
この大外でつなぐなやっぱ不安定なのでフラフープが飛んで行くことがちょっとね無理
だと思いました
全部普通にくっつけました今ホラー70フラフープがこちらに完成しましたこれ打倒の
一回でなら頭のプランループだねその力がかかるのでとてもねエクササイズになると
いうわけでございますツイ
2うわぁ
ああああああ
聖堂